depuis hier quarante neuf baleines
globicéphales était échoué sur une plage
au nord est de l'île de java la
communauté locale s'est rapidement
mobilisée pour venir en aide à ces
mammifères marins les efforts déployés
ont permis de sauver 3 cétacés et de les
relâcher en eaux vives mais 46 n'ont pas
eu cette chance
les secouristes étaient parvenus à
repousser plusieurs baleines au large
mais elle revenait constamment comme si
elle cherchait à leur mère raconte la
gouverneure de la province du java
oriental
le problème ajoute elle sait que leur
mère sont déjà mortes et que les
baleineaux continue de les chercher ces
mammifères marins sont connus pour vivre
et se déplacer en groupe on les surnomme
les dauphins pilotes car on les voit
souvent accompagné les bateaux nous
enquêtons toujours sur la cause de leur
échouement mais il est probable que le
leader du groupe de baleines se soient
perdus ou ait pris une mauvaise
direction a déclaré cet écologiste
selon les spécialistes le globicéphale
est reconnue comme une espèce qui
s'échouent malheureusement trop souvent
et dans cette région du monde entre la
pollution par le plastique les filets
abandonnées et les courants croiser les
dangers qui le guettent sont nombreux